concepts come alive is to up the ante
all the time we've been doing that for
years but we need to do it again and
when it comes to
the ownership stake that we need
uh women and minority-owned firms to
have
one of the areas to look at is an
affordable housing
because there's going to be a lot of
investment going forward in affordable
housing one thing the city will never
stop doing
is investing in affordable housing
there's a lot of work to be done there's
a lot of construction to be done
and firms led by people of color need
many more opportunities
to have a piece of that pie so our
department of housing preservation
development
has been leading the way with a new
approach and i want to thank everyone
there for their creativity their energy
and here to talk about what equitable
ownership will look like
in affordable housing as our
commissioner for hpd
louise carroll
thank you mia de blasio and thank you
also to deputy mayor thompson
and the first lady for your leadership
on the task force
for racial inclusion and equity
lots of businesses have grown in the
city from
startups to wealthy companies
many of them grew by doing a lot of work
with new york city government yet rarely
have we seen minority
and women-owned firms mwbes
get this kind of opportunity for success
this is wrong and this administration is
working very hard to change that
minorities and women owned businesses
they
form 85 percent of the population
if they don't prosper the city doesn't
prosper
most mwbe firms are part of black and
brown communities that have been hardest
hit by covet
these firms hire and train workers
in their neighborhoods many workers have
lost jobs due to this pandemic
and these workers need help right now so
dollars spent with mwbes
when will enable people to get back on
their feet
this is part of how new york city will
recover
from this pandemic more than that
money spent with mwbes will help repair
the damage
caused by decades of exclusion of people
of color
from business opportunities and jobs
and even more more than that when mwbes
and community not-for-profits own
property
it is harder to dislocate them from
their community
or gentrify them out of their community
that is why starting now hpd
when we award sites for affordable
housing development
we will only consider teams that have
an mwbe or not-for-profit partner
and that partner must own at least
25 of the project
in the past nwbs and not-for-profits
have been included
in development teams but when it comes
to the money
it just wasn't there we are putting an
end to that
from now on an mwbe
or a not-for-profit partner must both
have
a meaningful ownership stake in a
project
as well as a financial stake in a
project
new york city is a great place it has
helped so many people from every corner
of the country and indeed every corner
of the world
people like me get a foothold in their
business
or launch their careers the people in
the city have gone on
to help others
and are admired everywhere but it all
starts with opportunity
when we open the doors of opportunity to
all people we unleash a flood of talent
and what that does is benefit all of us
we know that
immediately it will be in a request for
proposals that hpd is issuing tomorrow
for the development of vacant land in
the bedford-stuyvesant
part of brooklyn but this is just the
beginning
there's more to come and i thank you
again mr mayor for your leadership on
this important issue
thank you so much commissioner and
commissioner you you said a lot of
important things there but
i want to hearken back to the point you
made about this city's greatness
and who contributes to our greatness and
who gets recognized and who doesn't get
recognized
i remember correctly your family's
originally from st lucia
yes and you know you came to this city
and brought your skills and talents and
now you're creating affordable housing
for all new yorkers this is the new york
story
that everyone has had opportunity
but not everyone has had equal
opportunity and that's what we need to
fix
and actually making sure that the money
is distributed
fairly and putting tough rules in place
to do it
makes a world of difference so you heard
from the commissioner
her story is an example of exactly what
we want to foster and support
and you heard about the new approach but
now i want to hear from someone who can
tell you what it means
for the businesses that will have the
opportunity to grow
and to reach out to their communities
and bring
more and more people into that
opportunity
and it really is important to understand
on a human level
what it means every time a minority
women-owned business
gets a contract what literally happens
to create empowerment in that community
so here to speak about it her story is
one of great success
she is the ceo and founder of r.f
wilkins
consultants friends celia wilkins
raheem we welcome you thank you thank
you mayor
thank you for having me i also want to
thank the first lady and deputy mayor
thompson
for all of the amazing leadership on the
task force
of racial equity and inclusion and last
but not least
i want to thank you commissioner carol
thank you
you know it was only june when myself
the new york real estate chamber and the
black business collaborative
came to you on behalf of black business
owners
across new york city we came to you
and many other agency officials
we were concerned we were concerned
because coved
was impacting 40 percent of black
business
businesses across the united states we
were concerned because when we looked at
new york city we saw that black
businesses
were not having equitable access to new
york city contracts
when the collaborative came to you we
wanted to see a shift
we wanted new york city contract to
reflect the black population across the
city
we wanted black developers to have
ownership across affordable housing
development
we wanted oversight over agency-wide
procurement
and commissioner you heard us so thank
you
you know the truth is challenges for
black businesses did not start with
coving
for far too long we have been able not
able to have
equitable access across contracts every
day i speak to developers
and business owners who say why should i
even try to participate in bid
when i will be overlooked why should i
try to access a development team when i
may just be leveraged as a mwbe check
you know when i look at these things
i understand the concerns these
developers would share that black
businesses
hire black subcontractors black
developers hire black subcontractors
who in turn hire black workforce who in
turn come from black communities
a lot of the communities where
affordable housing is being developed
so it only makes sense that affordable
housing developers
look and represent and feel and
understand the communities
that development is happening in you
know
to conclude this i
just kind of go back to my story in 2011
i founded arf wilkins consultants
at that time i had no money
i had no relationships i had
very limited access today
we hire a diverse community of people
mayor you just talked about the new york
story and the new york story has been my
story
not only do we have hire a diverse
community of people
but we have implemented
some of the most difficult logistic
project management
and compliance projects across the state
of new york
every day is difficult but i truly stand
on the back of the black business owners
who came before me
today is not only about contracts
it's about nourishing the black
ecosystem
it's about nourishing black businesses
and activating the next generation of
leaders
who will hopefully see more black
businesses more black business
participation
there's still so much more to do but we
have
business owners who are ready for a
piece of the
economic pie we have a forward-thinking
mayor we have
agency commissioners like you
commissioner carroll
who will ensure that black businesses
are not lost
in the implementation of mwb programs
every step towards equitable
participation for black businesses
every step towards acknowledging the
disparity in the disparity
every step towards supporting black
business growth
is a step in the right direction so mr
mayor thank you thank you thank you for
your commitment
and we look forward to partnering with
you in the future and continuing to
support the growth of black businesses
thank you thank you thank you so much
francillia and what a powerful
presentation
i can see why you succeeded and i really
appreciate your energy and i appreciate
your hopeful message
even in a tough time but francilla's
story another great new york story as a
reminder
that great story can't just be for some
people and then the
latter gets kicked away and others don't
get to participate it has to be for
everyone
has to be for all the generations coming
up and when we actually
act with that spirit of fairness and
equity amazing things
can happen and one of the things i felt
as i was listening to you was
you are already seeing the future that
we
again we we're going through so much but
we've got to get one foot into the
future
and if we do these smart approaches to
share the wealth in a better way a lot
more people going to prosper and it's
going to bring this city back a lot
stronger so
thank you for helping us light the way
francillia okay everybody
let's conclude with our indicators
and go over these now first daily number
of people
admitted to new york city hospitals for
suspected covid19
threshold 200 patients today's report
115 patients with a 34.45
confirmed positivity level again we're
watching this really
carefully this is the indicator that has
been different than the others
very concerned to say the least i
haven't seen as much growth there as
expected that's a good thing but we are
watching
very very carefully so far again our
hospitals
are doing quite well handling the
challenge number two though is a
different matter new reported cases on a
seven-day average threshold 550 cases
this number just keeps growing and this
worries me a lot
1255 cases and we want to keep testing
everyone again i'm going to
constantly remind people get out there
and get tested and that will account for
some of the growth of those numbers
but clearly the trend goes beyond simply
the fact that more and more people
getting tested
that keep a close eye there and now the
percentage of people
tested citywide positive for covet 19
threshold 5
today's report 2.36 today's seven-day
rolling average
3.01
okay a few words in spanish back on the
topic of
how we ensure fairness and opportunity
for all the people of this city
nuestra lucha contra la pandemia include
the unesco
with that let's turn to our colleagues
in the media
and please let me know the name and
outlet of each journalist
hi all we'll now begin our q a with us
today is hpd commissioner louise carroll
school's chancellor richard carranza
health commissioner dr dave chochki
and francilia francilia wilkins rahim
and senior advisor dr j varma with that
we'll go to andrew from wnbc
good morning mr mayor and everyone on
the call you spoke repeatedly this
morning about new tough standards and
more stringent rules that you'll need
to get the schools back open but other
than getting a higher percentage
of kids educators etc to get coveted
tests and you mentioned the need to get
consent forms
what possible tough standards are you
talking about you're already
disinfecting the buildings you're
already requiring masks and ppe
so what standards are you talking about
uh andrew we're working that through
but we want to look at a geographical
issues we want to look at uh test
positivity levels we want to look at a
lot of things
i i don't think it's entirely helpful
your question is totally fair but i
don't want to start
you know just surmising and throwing
things out randomly we're looking at
anything and everything that can
contribute to making it safer
in an atmosphere where the positivity
levels around us are growing and this is
the x factor we got to keep in mind
we came up with the original plan in
august
the city the city as a whole was doing
very very well
and yet you'll remember so many people
said don't open schools it's too
dangerous to open schools we said we'll
put together a gold standard
the cleaning the ventilation the social
distancing the mask wearing all these
things
the testing and will prove to you that
schools can be safe and we did
now we see a gathering storm and we're
fighting back this second wave
we are pausing we are resetting the
equation
we need to come to a new agreement with
the state with the people
of the city with parents with
all the folks who work in schools on
what's going to work for this
new time but clearly more testing is
crucial
and clear standards that everyone can uh
understand
and being really clear that we want to
take the bar even higher we said we had
a gold standard and it was
now we got to find out how to even add
to that by looking around the world
figure out what's worked what would be
additional elements
because we do see the impact
unfortunately coveted as having a lot of
communities
and for schools to be open we have to be
absolutely certain we can keep our kids
and our adults in the school system safe
go ahead andrew
are you being unreasonably optimistic
when you suggest to parents and families
that this might
only be a short-term shutdown at the
same time you're saying
that indoor dining and gyms are about to
close that all of new york city is about
to be designated in orange zone
and we know with thanksgiving and
christmas coming up and seemingly
uncontrolled small gatherings taking
place indoors
shouldn't we expect that the seven day
average will go much higher than three
percent
couldn't this school shutdown last into
january or even longer
every question you had a lot of points
in there andrew everything you said
is a fair concern i didn't hear a single
thing and i'd say how dare you no i
thought all of that was fair
but i'd say a couple things one new
yorkers are clearly getting the memo
that we are in a tough new situation
people are acting accordingly uh you you
see
really extraordinary levels of mask
usage out there i am
certain a lot of people have canceled
their travel plans i am certain
a lot of people are going to keep their
holiday gatherings very limited
i think people are making those
adjustments right now
and in fact these other limitations
coming with the orange zone are going to
help us knock down the disease that's
the whole
point of these kind of restrictions they
help turn things around
we've got to set up a structure led by
our healthcare leadership
that we believe will keep the school
safe now we've got a running start
because we've had schools be
extraordinary safe extraordinarily safe
so far so we know
something that we did not know in august
and september we have a body of evidence
of what works
now you're adding to the equation a
tougher dynamic but we believe we can
compensate for that tougher dynamic with
additional
measures that's what we need to do
quickly
put that into play and then go make it
work
so yeah a tough environment around us
but
i really think as the other restrictions
come into play and as new yorkers change
their behavior
we have the opportunity to start driving
these numbers
down next is ravine from humber
from hamodia good morning mr mayor uh as
the
public schools are being closed now and
we know uh
there may be some more closures coming
with new york city being put into an
iron zone soon
are there any uh exceptions going to be
made for special needs students for whom
the remote learning is really not
feasible
a very important question rivanna thank
you
this is one of the topics we're going to
talk
you're talking with all the stakeholders
and with the state
unquestionably the kids who have the
greatest needs are special needs kids
and the kids for whom in person takes on
even greater value
is our specialty kids their families
need it so this is part of the
discussion
of how to come back quickly with a
special focus on
special needs kids um needs kids
go ahead um and now that the public
schools are closed city wide and
as we said the whole city might go into
an orange zone
uh would you consider uh suspending
alternate side considering you know that
the parents can't uh
bring their kids to school the kids are
home from school all day
um first of all i think from what the
governor said yesterday and the numbers
uh certainly reflect it i don't think
it's uh
if the city is going into an orange zone
it's a win
the the city's going to orange zone
again i i'm being very straightforward
to all the folks i've heard the comments
about you know how could indoor dining
still be open in gyms and i wish they
could stay open i really do
because i feel for the business owners i
feel for the people who have put their
lives into building up a business i feel
for the people who care about those
businesses
but revenge it's not it's not if it's
when and by any normal count just
looking at the state's own number system
uh
we're talking a week or two before we're
in that orange zone status
i'm sorry to say that but that's the
blunt truth in terms of alternate side
we're going to look at that
again we don't have a determination on
that we're not in the situation we were
in
in the spring it's thank god not that
kind of dislocation happening in this
city
but we're certainly going to look at
alternate side uh parking and reevaluate
that situation
as these changing dynamics occur
go ahead next is emily from new york one
good morning mayor de blasio good
morning emily how are you
i'm well how are you did you watch
governor cuomo's news conference
yesterday
i did not i got a summary of the
different announcements he made but i
didn't watch the actual news conference
have you been in touch with him today
and when you spoke with him yesterday
you noted of course that you had several
conversations with them
about new restrictions for the city uh
what what
he looks to do with the city did you
tell him the schools were closing or did
you ask him
i let him know we had very good
conversations we had another number of
conversations yesterday
i let him know that first we had
seen the number come up we were checking
it again because it was
literally exactly 3.00
so i told him we were quickly making
sure that number was accurate
and then i told him that that would
activate the closure
and we talked about what would happen
next
and what would take the schools back but
we also talked about the orange zone
he made very clear to me that by
everything they were seeing
it was moving in that direction and
essentially
a given that new york city would end up
in the orange zone
and that we all needed to prepare
accordingly and we talked about the
interplay of that reality with the
school's reality just what i was talking
about earlier that hopefully that's
going to help us
continue to drive down the numbers
overall and what it would take
to bring schools back so i think it was
a very good conversation very clear
and you know at the time he was going
out to his press conference was
just about the time that we had to our
announcement because we had to let
schools know
uh once we had concluded all of our
recheck and our discussions with the
state we had to let schools know
so they could take the actions they
needed to
to give out whatever devices they had
available give out whatever materials
they needed to give to kids
and prepare for the shutdown so that's
how it played out yesterday
next is nolan from the new york post
good morning everybody
hey nolan how are you i'm all right um
mr mary this three person standard has
been around for a long time
and i know you keep promising that the
state and the city are working
together to develop a plan to reopen the
schools
hitting the three percent threshold why
wasn't one already crafted
nolan look it is an obvious question
and i will just tell you in the real
world dynamics we're dealing with
that we've all been trying to see if we
could take every conceivable action
to avoid the closure to begin with and
that's where the focus has been all the
actions in terms of testing
public education outreach efforts
efforts uh zones anything
that could help us not get to this point
and obviously there's been a lot of
other things we had to prepare for
as well so what i have learned sometimes
is sometimes it is hard to
imagine the next phase until you get
there you do your damnedest to plan
ahead but you can't always do that
we have a really ever-changing situation
here
but the conversations are quickly
progressing i think some of the lines
are already becoming clear what it's
going to take
and again we need a little time to reset
in any
scenario to get to this new approach we
need a little bit of time to reset the
equation
so either way you slice it when we give
people the update in the next few days
uh it will then take a little bit of
time to implement it
and make it work for our schools go
ahead
and sticking with the three percent
threshold one of the
concerns or one of the factors in the
decision making apparently
was if the workforce would show up to
schools
provided the three percent was hit you
have repeatedly said there was no
formal agreement between the city and
the teachers union
over the three percent rule was there an
informal agreement was there a
gentleman's agreement was there some
sort of understanding
between you and mike mulver that if
three percent were to happen the schools
were to close and that it was an
invaluable agreement
no it's just i i appreciate your
question but it's just not how things
happened
um look what we saw
after september was a workforce that
wanted to be in the schools
and in fact one of the interesting
things i think has not been represented
sufficiently in the public discourse is
how intensely
teachers felt the impact of being around
kids again i heard this
constantly that it was one thing you
know in july or august to think about it
people were obviously concerned
about the health dynamics but once they
got into school then
we heard from a huge number of educators
and staff they wanted to stay there they
felt it was their mission so a fact even
the first day
when i was out in elmhurst at pre-k uh
you could just
excitement among the adults was
extraordinary
now the deal was we had a call
back before the final decisions about
school opening
with our health care leadership i
remember very vividly
the discussion of the three percent and
the feeling that we had to set a very
strict standard
we had to have in effect a social
contract
with the people of the city with the
educators and staff with the parents who
said
we will protect your children we will
protect everyone in the school community
we're so certain we can do it we're
going to set this gold standard in terms
of all these precautions
and we're going to put a very tough
standard on
when we would close we wanted it to be a
tough standard and people heard that and
was actually one of the things that
encouraged people to come back and to
participate and to feel comfortable
we weren't going to change that once
that standard was set we were going to
live by it
but nolan remember the reason we're
having even
the discussion is because unfortunately
the second wave has been bearing down on
us
that's not a fiction that's a fact and
the three percent is a very real number
so it was not a collective bargaining
issue it was not
a deal with the union it was something
our health care team and i decided
separate from any discussions with uh
the union because we thought it would be
the thing that would give people
confidence that they could come back and
it did
next is james from pixel 11
good morning mr mayor to everyone on the
call good morning james
good to see you um look at the end of
last week
you let parents know that they should
prepare for schools to close
and eventually obviously they did now
you're saying restaurant and gym
closures will
almost certainly happen so what's your
specific message
of preparation to owners of restaurants
and gyms
and how do you feel about the economic
effects of of those closures
i feel very first of all humanly very
sad
for these business owners a lot of whom
i've talked to
uh here we are you know talking about
how to support
uh small businesses and mwbes and that
is our future so the notion that for
another period of time they may have to
be shut down is very painful it's
horrible for them it's horrible for
their employees
and i always come back to the family mom
and pop store that people put their
whole life into
i don't want to see this happen to them
but you know the the facts the science
the data are just screaming at us right
now that
we have a huge challenge and we have to
beat it back
james remember our hospital system is
strong right now
thank god we're not seeing the icu's
flooded
thank god the number of people were
losing is stayed low and we need to
fight to save every life
but the overall numbers of cases keep
growing
and we've got to do something different
to fight this back
so the state standards are clear
the governor did exactly the right thing
he said look everyone
this orange zone status involves real
restrictions
it's coming you can just see by the
chart of the state numbers it's coming
it's you know a week or two away by my
account
and it's what do you do to prepare i say
to the business owners you know i
i would say know that this is a very
strong likelihood
prepare um i hope them that there for
them the very best in the meantime
and that they can do anything they can
to tie it over we'll help them in any
way we can
anybody who needs help can call our
small business services department
they'll always try to find ways to help
a business
and the other thing i'd say is unlike
any discussion we had before a few weeks
ago
now we have vaccines there's light at
the end of the tunnel
we have different leadership coming in
washington hold on in any way you can
because
in a matter of months we're going to be
in a much much better situation
so there's hope go ahead james
uh thank you uh and can you explain the
process by which
the school closure announcement was made
yesterday i mean the news conference
kept being moved back in time until it
happened mid-afternoon
with the closure announcement what
happened leading up to
that announcement why did it take all
day was there
maybe a chance that you and others
involved maybe even the teachers union
were considering possibly not closing
james again i wouldn't say all day i
understand everyone's
impatience on such an important matter
uh
you're talking about a difference of
four or five hours which
you know really isn't earth shaking in
the end and
parents had been warned in advance and
they heard the news
you know by around two o'clock so they
could prepare for the next day and i
don't
i'm not saying that with anything but
sorrow and understanding that it's a
burden for parents but
again one we had the irony of the number
landing exactly on the razor's edge at
3.00 and we needed to go back and make
sure that was accurate
two we needed to have real conversations
with the state about what would happen
next
and that as i said what became not just
a conversation about what happens next
with the schools but what would happen
next with the whole city
and the governor and i talked through
what he was thinking
and what he was preparing to say about
orange zones and it made very clear
the direction that we were going to go
in so we needed to it became a much
bigger conversation we decided it was
important to get all those pieces
clarified
and then go out with a lot of the
answers in place
and that's what it came down to that we
had a lot to work through
we worked it through and then we
announced it
go ahead next we have jacob from jewish
insider
hi mr mayor uh you you said that
we might go into a full lockdown
uh if the rate goes up jacob i'm gonna
stop you i'm sorry to interrupt
orange zone is not full lockdown i
really want to be careful about that
uh orange zone is definitely a better
status than a red zone and not a full
lockdown so i
just want to make sure we don't
overstate go ahead
right but i was saying that once you go
into an orange zone and you reach the
peak
and you get into a red zone that means a
lockdown so my question is
that if that is the case
uh will you not look any more at certain
zip codes
and neighborhoods bought um as new york
city as a whole
i think first of all i want to respect
the state's role in making the ultimate
decisions
but what i'd say to you is i think right
now we're moving
rapidly away from uh right now
away from uh zip code focus and to
something
broader and again this is all evolving
with the facts
and the data the zip code information we
provide
still has a lot of value because it's
directing where we're sending testing
where we're sending outreach and we
still have a lot of ability to hopefully
contain
problems neighborhood by neighborhood
and the zip code information is going to
have tremendous value
going forward as we fight against the
disease but
right now again it is an overwhelming
likelihood
and i think it's this close to a
certainty that new york city will be in
that orange zone status in a week or two
that's as far as we can tell right now
the whole city
so i don't think for the immediate
future it's going to be done on anything
more
regionalized from what i'm hearing from
the state so far
i do not assume we have to go to red
zone uh this is something we again i
keep telling people to fight and i think
a lot of people are fighting back
the orange zone alone is going to have a
very big impact
and if people are really smart about not
traveling and really careful about
holiday gatherings i do not think it's a
foregone conclusion you end up in a red
zone so
you know people are concerned about
ending up in a red zone can do something
about it with our own behavior
and we've proven before how much impact
that can make
go ahead jacob so
some people are confused you know with
the reopening process the closures with
the ongoing bickering
between you and the governor can you
look people in the eye and say
all decisions that are made are done
with the main objective
of defeating the virus or until we have
a vaccine
not to meet any metrics or any goals
i i couldn't understand i'm sure i can
look people in the eye but i couldn't
understand where you were going there
could you just say it a little more
simply what is what is the question
that all the decisions are made are not
to meet any certain metrics or
any uh deals with the labor unions but
the main objective
is to actually bring down the infection
rate defeat the virus or until
there's a vaccine yeah jacob look first
of all i respect the question but let's
be real here
we were the epicenter of the crisis
we fought back based on decisions made
by the city and state both
and again a lot of directional unity
sometimes we had disagreements that's
fine
but the broad direction was very
conservative in terms of health care
very strong focus on science and data
brought this city back
made it one of the safest places in the
country then we said we're going to open
schools
i couldn't tell you the thousands of
voices that said you can't open schools
it won't be safe we did it we made it
safe
then we said look there's going to be a
standard of what it would lead to
a closure schools we kept to that
standard
folks who say that's anything but a
focus on science and data are not
looking at the facts
now again i've asked been asked this
question where do we get the three
percent
i can happily have some of the
participants in the original conference
call talk to you
the three percent decision was made with
our health care leadership
before school started and of course with
our education leadership
out of both abundance of caution and a
belief that we needed a social contract
with our parents with our educators with
our staff
that we needed to show we meant so much
business
in terms of opening school safely that
we would stake our claim
at a level lower than anybody lower than
world health organization or estate or
anybody that's how confident we were
that we could open schools safely keep
them open
we made that decision and i'm absolutely
convinced jacob it was part of what
allowed us to open schools
and gain people's confidence and it will
be part of what allows us to
reopen schools that we kept faith with
what we said
it was not about any specific union or
all unions it was about a much bigger
consideration of what would work for the
city
and i was on that call our health
leadership our educational leadership i
remember the specific call that's how
the decision got made
go ahead we have time for two more first
we'll go to matches from newsday
hi good morning uh mr mayor uh for dr
uh choxy or dr varma um
consistency or promises aside as we
speak here and now
what is the scientific and
epidemiological basis for the three
percent threshold versus a higher one
and i will say as they get into this
answer matt
uh i certainly remember dr varma's voice
on that call he and i had quite a
dialogue on that call about the three
percent and what do it mean in terms of
case numbers et cetera
i believe dr choxie was on that call to
uh the day we decided the three percent
so
go ahead into it first jay and then uh
dave
great thank you very much so uh we'll go
back in time
so when we were making the decision
about what threshold to use
um as the mayor has said we were very
concerned about making sure that our
school system
was the safest possible and quite
honestly we chose an extremely
conservative approach
and the time we were making that
decision there was a very conscious
reason to do that we needed to make sure
that our school system was sitting so we
could open it up for in-person learning
we chose three percent because based on
what we predicted to be
the number of tests that we would be
doing in new york by the time the
schools were opening
we believed that that was a reasonably
good threshold to estimate how much
transmission there might be
broadly in the community as a whole and
because we didn't know at that time
how safe we could really make our
schools we were concerned that this
would mean that
teachers students would be have
undiagnosed infection
coming into schools and potentially
transmitting it to other people
that was one concern the second concern
is as part of
our approach our rigorous approach
we chose a very conservative standard
for closing classrooms and closing
buildings
and we were concerned also that as the
transmission in the community rises
this would result in a lot of disruption
to classroom and building closures
so those two considerations together us
not knowing
how well we would do at protecting
transmission in the schools
and second our concerns about the
disruption of
uh classroom and building closures were
the reasons for that threshold
now we know more the beauty of science
is that
you know you change your views on things
when the science and the evidence
changes as well so i think that gets to
the point that the chancellor and the
mayor have made that
we're going to work very actively to
focus on this new phase
and how we can modify our proposals to
adjust for a new phase of the epidemic
dr joxi uh thank you sir well i think dr
varma
explained it quite well the one point
that i will add to it
is that um you know the other thing that
is different
uh now compared to a few months ago is
we have um further layers of protection
that we have built into our approach
for schools so you know i know there has
been a lot of
focus justifiably on the percent
positivity
uh as you know one of the key uh
indicators and thresholds
um but really i think of it as one of
three uh you know overall pieces
uh with respect to how we should think
about this epidemiol
epidemiologically so the first is what's
happening citywide
um that's uh that's what the test
positivity tells us
the second is what's actually happening
uh within
the school and so that's why the school
testing
regime that we put in place gives us
valuable additional information as dr
varma said
the third really important piece is the
situation room
that the department of education the
test and trace core and the health
department and others have really
collaborated on
to make sure that we act very quickly
when uh
cases are identified within the school
so those three pieces working in concert
give us a much different instrument
to be able to understand what's
happening with spread
but then most importantly to take micro
targeted actions that help us keep
students safe
go ahead matt okay so go so going
forward
to you meaning dr chakshi and dr obama
think the standard should be higher
well i'm just going to say one thing as
we lead into them we're we're
right now unquestionably going to be
having higher standards and working with
the state and
other stakeholders on that and i think
it's
self-evident from the numbers we're
seeing why we need to change the
approach but doctors you can go into
detail
yes i can go ahead go
sorry about that jay i'll i'll just
start quickly to um to say
yes uh you know the short answer is yes
there will be higher standards
um and uh that's our commitment uh both
because of what we have learned over the
last few months but really importantly
because the broader context that we're
in
is that we do see uh cases on the rise
across new york city
and so we have to redouble our
safeguards in schools
as well as in other places dr varma
nothing more for me dad okay great go
ahead
finally we have marcia from wcbs
uh good morning mr mayor and everybody
on the call
i guess the question that i have is this
the number of people
today who've been critical of the way
the closing of the schools was handled
most notably um jimani williams and mark
trager the head of the education
commission who said that
we're being led into chaos because
there were no plans to reopen but also
that there was a no plans to really make
sure that people who didn't have devices
or didn't have interconnect
internet connections um had them and
what uh
both the uh public advocate and and uh
chair traeger said was
that the sad thing was that we entered
the school system opening them knowing
that there were tens of thousands of
people
kids who did not have devices or
internet connection and were closing
schools with the same situation
so what would you like to say to them
and their criticism of the lack of a
plan and the lack of
equipment i think they just don't have
their facts right
uh and i'll let the chancellor join in
on this
um you know i appreciate that there are
professional critics in this society but
i really think there has to be
recognition of the work that people did
to close the digital divide to do
something that never been done before
back in april as the pandemic was
horrendous
to put these devices in the hands of
kids and i i don't quite
understand why the same question keeps
being asked when in fact the evidence is
that immense work was done to provide
devices to address any problem with
devices to provide
service if they need a different service
that work has literally
been done now family by family for kids
in shelters
that sometimes it's true that we don't
have as many devices as we
want to but the
the bottom line is it's just been an
endless effort
to provide free technology
to any family who needs it and that's
never stopped and it's been
consistent and i think it deserves uh
respect
and the people who've done the work have
really put their heart and soul into
making sure
kids got what they needed go ahead uh
chancellor
uh thank you mr mayor i will only add
marcia that uh
you know since march we did we've
delivered uh ordered and delivered over
350 000 devices
uh as students have devices sometimes
it's their own devices it's devices
they've gotten from the school those
devices break then it becomes a need for
another device
we've ordered over 100 000 devices again
we have about 40 000 of those devices
that are arriving on a daily basis
then we're inserting lte cards into
those devices so that students are able
to connect to the internet
so this is a constantly moving number
it's not a set number
that remains static and then nothing
happens so you feel it or you don't feel
this is a constantly evolving
uh situation and the other thing that i
would mention is that there is a real
supply side
issue here we are not the only school
system in america
actually in the world that is ordering
computers and devices
so the manufacturers are having a hard
time filling these orders
and while we've been prioritized and
we're getting these devices
ahead of many other systems because of
our size
it's just important to recognize that as
the mayor has stated
we are literally putting a computer
device in the hands of every one of our
1.1 million students
with also understanding that devices
break with also
understanding that sometimes there's
connectivity issue with also
understanding that
not all families have come forward and
said i need a device so
i'm just going to remind folks now you
can go onto our website schools.nyc.gov
it's very simple there to
request a device you can also call 311
and you can also make sure your school
knows that you need a device any of
those
methods will make sure that we get you
the technology that
that you need go ahead marcia
so another question that they ask
is that if you knew going into opening
the schools that there was a possibility
of a second wave
and a possibility that you would in fact
reach that three percent
why was there no plan to
uh figure out how you were going to come
back
once you reach that number marcia it's
just there have been a lot of different
pieces we had to account for
for a long time we were doing really
well in this city
for a long time it looked like we could
hold off a second wave we're
still battling the second wave right now
and
where we are in the city is so much
better than other parts of the country
so our focus was not on what to do if
our focus was getting our schools up and
running unlike any
of the large urban school systems in
america was getting our schools up and
running
making them safe supporting our kids and
families
that's where we've been putting our time
and energy and
in recent days is the first time we had
to confront the notion
that we might hit this standard we've
been working to set a new standard
in a new environment not a theoretical
one we could have said a long time ago
but
one that actually fits this moment and
the facts we know now and the better
information we have
on what works and we're going to come
out with that standard
in a matter of days and it will take a
few days to apply it
but our goal is to come back as quickly
as possible with
even higher standards and make it work
so i i
you know the what ifs i don't get lost
in we've got work to do right now
but what we do know if you didn't know
back in august
we now have proof positive we can keep
our kids our educators our staff safe
and we're going to reset the equation
for the new facts we have
and make them safe again and get our
schools back
so everyone as we conclude today look
everyone's been through so much
i know and and it's ever-changing you
know a lot of times the questions i get
whether it's from the media or everyday
new yorkers it's the same point why is
everything changing so much
let me tell you i wish i wish the
coronavirus
would ever give us a stationary target
but it is the most moving target
situation i've ever seen in my life
that's the coronavirus always changing
always
clever unfortunately trying to outwit us
but we need to outwit
it so we do that by doubling down on
what works the testing
the mask wearing being smart about
avoiding those
large indoor gatherings avoiding travel
this is how we fight back the schools
have been shut temporarily but only
temporarily
they will be back and they'll be safer
than ever the city
is going to go through some tough times
in the coming weeks
but we'll fight back and the vaccine is
coming
we couldn't say that even just a few
weeks ago now we can say it with 100
assurance so let's double down on this
fight
let's overcome this moment and i have
not a doubt in my mind that new york
city will come back
and we will be stronger for this painful
experience and we will make it a better
city
thank you everyone
you